all right today we're going to uh go
back to Tech talk my favorite place in
the world
War it never changes
you know one of the things that they
love to do on Tech talk is to complain
about uh work as if any of them have
jobs but if they do have jobs and they
go to those jobs begrudgingly uh and
they like to complain about it I don't
like my job and uh
I don't think I'm gonna go anymore we've
talked about this on the show it's
become a whole movement it takes on
different names quiet quitting is one of
them but all these different names they
use really just another these all terms
that really stand for laziness that they
are lazy and they're trying to repackage
and Rebrand their laziness to make it uh
I don't know virtuous or trendy so we're
gonna check out some uh tick tocks from
some lazy people basically lazy tick
tocks let's start with uh clip three do
you ever just sit down and think wow
humans really have to pay money to stay
alive we have to pay for food we have to
pay for water we have to pay for shelter
how does that make sense the universe
put us on Earth a planet that has
everything humans need to survive and
yet we've evolved to the point where we
have to pay money to stay alive I don't
I don't understand that I'm sure you
don't understand it guys I just had this
thought things cost money did you know
that no way way wow dude mind-blowing
you're blow I you're blowing my mind
right now I can't even I'm disoriented
all those things cost money that you
mentioned right right now uh food
shelter clothing and it doesn't have to
be that way uh there was a time in human
history when that was not the case when
actually you wouldn't have paid money
per se there was a time in human history
when money didn't exist if you can
believe it you go all the way back to
like hunter-gatherer cultures I'm dying
help me and there's no money but do you
know what the other option is then it's
that you have to go out and do all that
stuff yourself
okay so either you can pay someone to
give you food
or you can go out and get the food
yourself and grow the food go into the
forest and try to hunt for it and you
know the other thing on that on that
system is if it doesn't work and you're
not able to grow the food there's a
drought or you go into the forest and
you're not able to catch uh to to bag
any game and then you know what happens
you die and your family dies and
everybody dies
those are the only two options there is
no third option so no matter what work
is involved it's just how it's you can
work to make money to then go buy the
stuff you need or you can cut all that
out and you can just work yourself to
get the stuff but um that is not going
to be the utopian scenario that you
apparently imagine in your head but of
course this guy on Tick Tock he he
doesn't want either of those options
like this is not he's not uh he's not
making a pitch
for going back to agrarian Societies or
going all the way back to
hunter-gatherer cultures he's not making
a pitch for that he would hate that no
what he wants is to do nothing
at all and have all that stuff given to
him but what he doesn't mention or maybe
he doesn't quite understand himself and
he does understand he doesn't care is
that well that would still mean like no
matter what work is required to obtain
all that stuff food shelter all the
necessities of life clothing someone has
to do the work because it doesn't just
uh the universe does not just provide it
okay it doesn't make a pizza uh fall out
of the sky right onto your lap
someone needs to make that happen
the work's going to be done now what you
want is for someone else to do all the
work and for you to pay nothing
and to be given it so what you want to
slate you want slave labor that's what
you're asking for you want slaves you
know what companies looking out for you
when they actually upgrade your service
and they don't charge you for it pure
talk just added data to every new and
existing plan they're also including a
mobile hotspot with each new plan as
well with no price increase whatsoever
if you've considered pure talk before
but you haven't made the switch you need
to take a look again for just twenty
dollars a month you'll get unlimited
talk text and now 50 percent more 5G
data plus a mobile hotspot I love pure
talk not only do they offer great
services but they also happen to be
veteran owned and they only hire the
best United states-based customer
service team available remember you vote
with how you spend your money so stop
supporting woke wireless companies that
don't support you when you go to
puretalk.com Walsh you'll save an
additional 50 off your first month
because they actually value you that's
puretalk.com Walsh puretalk Wireless for
Americans buy Americans
that job
I don't know who needs to hear this
today but that job okay I myself am like
a professional job quitter because I'll
do I'll dip
um
so this company that I work for that
will go unnamed
uh we had some beef because they
scheduled a meeting my availability by
the way is from 9am to 5 p.m I have kids
I'm a single mother okay
um I have to get them to school that's
when I can be at work anyway they
scheduled meeting they don't offer a
zoom option the meeting's an hour away
which will cost me twenty dollars in gas
I will be able to make after taking my
school my kids to school I will be able
to make about 30 minutes of that meeting
meaning I will get paid eight dollars
they are also not paying me travel time
so I'm spending twenty dollars in gas to
go to a meeting to make eight dollars
I'm missing all of that billable time
with my clients to go back
I let them know this is a problem for me
right I'm not going to pay to go today
shut up it's so boring gosh
imagine living with that every day those
kinds of complaints who cares that's the
first thing it's just boring just
telling your your boring story about
some inconvenience that's like who cares
you had to go and there's a meaning in
this what do you want what do you want
do you want you want life to be perfect
do you want everything to happen
perfectly how you want I only work from
9am to 5 p.m that's all I do
this is the time that I've decided and I
want to make all the money and I want
everything to work perfectly and if it
doesn't I'm gonna complain
on my Tick Tock video in my car I'm
eating a sandwich for some reason I'm a
single mother anyway you know you have
to think well why are you a single
mother that's another question it's
never asked I mean look there are some
single mothers that are single mothers
because uh and they're victims because
Dad ran out on them but through no fault
of their own so there are cases like
that for sure
um but I don't think that's the majority
of cases I don't think it's the majority
a lot of these single mothers they're
single mothers because they chose to be
that's what you wanted you chose this
I'm a single mother with nobody that
loves me on my child you chose it either
because you know you decided to be
sexually active when you're not married
you ended up with kids or you decided
that you want to kick your husband out
because you weren't feeling emotionally
fulfilled or whatever like that that's
also a lot of times what leads to the
single motherhood but then we then we
hear that it's like okay I've created
this problem for myself and now it's all
your problem
and then you go to your job well I look
I've created this impossible situation
in my life and you have to figure it out
I got news for you that's not your job
it's that is not your job's job to
figure out how to navigate
the obstacles that you have created in
your life you need to figure that out
why do you continually end up in jobs
that you want to quit why is that well
because you keep quitting
and No One's Gonna hire you you're not
going to get a better job because your
employers you know this is not a secret
especially when you put it on Tick Tock
you so your employers can see oh
look she's she she quits her all of her
jobs after six and a half weeks and
brags about it they're only going to
hire you for the kinds of roles where
they're where where that kind of
turnover rate is acceptable to them you
know you're just kind of like you're uh
you're a a number that they plug in and
then you leave and they plug in somebody
else you're only going to get the kind
of jobs that anyone could do and so your
employer knows okay you're gonna do this
for six weeks and you're gonna be gone
fine we'll find somebody else but you
don't make a lot of money in those jobs
because anyone can do them
and so you have almost almost no value
monetarily in the context of that job
but that's your fault because you keep
quitting today I don't feel like doing
[Music]
it